Wow life sure is amazing I can't wait to
grow other back they'll do that what was
I talking about again I think I'll just
have a little bit they say we grow up
fast but what if it wasn't just an
expression what if instead of living a
life for 80 years we went through our
lifecycle in just 24 hours yeah you
heard me
24 hours Oh within a day you would grow
from a newborn baby to a senior citizen
on your deathbed
what would your condensed lifestyle be
like and could this really happen to you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you only lived for 24 hours
let's face it we're all going to grow up
so before we speed up the clock let's
break down how aging actually works the
cells in your body are constantly
repairing and replicating themselves at
least they were when you hit your 20s
the process starts to slow down and
eventually stop this is the reason why
we age
the reason why cells can't repair
themselves forever is due to a part of
your DNA called telomeres telomeres
protect the ends of our chromosomes that
carry our DNA making sure that DNA
doesn't get damaged as the cells
replicate as we grow older the telomeres
will wear down and aren't able to
protect our DNA anymore the new cells
can't replace the old ones because
they're damaged goods good thing you've
got the time to work everything out
right wrong your whole lifespan is only
24 hours
here's a day-in-the-life example oh is
it a life in a day example at 6 a.m.
you're born welcome to the world at 6:18
a.m. you're already a year old you know
how parents always say the first year
goes by so fast well it did in 18
minutes during that time you'll grow by
one and a half centimeters per minute
your weight will also increase by one
third of a kilogram per minute talk
about a growth spurt okay it's 6:30 6:00
a.m. you're now two years old and able
to say about 50 words can you say what
if can you say subscribe can you all
right I'm moving on by 747 a.m. you're
ready for your first day of school
you're now six years old
the average person spends 13 years of
their life in school but you'll only
spend 3 hours and 51 minutes there 9:16
a.m. you'll start going through puberty
at 11 years of age we're gonna have to
talk about the birds and the bees beep
for lunch aren't we
11:20 a.m. happy 18th birthday 1222
you've just graduated from college and
are now 21 and a half years old
you always said you were going to work
on your career before finding love but
you may want to speed that up the
average person spends about 13 months
being romantic for you this is just over
18 minutes that's the ultimate example
of speed dating 1:24 p.m. you found your
significant other and what's this you're
starting a family just normally it would
take nine months but for you it's only
13 minutes oh and by the way you're 25
years old now 137 p.m. your baby is born
congratulations but raising a family is
no easy task and you need a job this is
a shame because out of your 24-hour life
you'll lose about four hours working at
your day job 253 p.m. happy 30th
birthday 6 o'clock p.m. happy 40th
birthday whoa hope this is going gonna
be 49 p.m. happy 50th birthday at this
point your hair is going gray and there
are wrinkles on your face life is going
by so fast you'll probably start your
midlife crisis should you buy a
motorcycle
this is going a little too fast for me I
mean you don't even have time to slow
down and get cozy and get some reading
in luckily our friends at blink us can
help with that
blink Asst is the only app that takes
the best insights from thousands of
non-fiction books and condenses them so
you can read or listen to them in just
15 minutes
since I only have a 24 hour life span
I've been trying to learn as much as I
can in that short amount of time brief
answers to the big questions by Stephen
Hawking is certainly helping with that
it goes from the origins of the universe
and black holes to human space
exploration and the dangers of
artificial intelligence all in one quick
read and truth be told I can't get
enough of it
the first 100 people to go to blink is
calm / what if we'll get one week for
free and if you decide to sign up for
the membership you'll get 25% off so
click the link and start your 7-day free
trial that's six more days than I have
so start blinking you whippersnappers
1:16 a.m. beer 65 now and it's time for
retirement enjoy some rest and
relaxation 6 a.m. at 81 years old you've
passed on from this mortal claim as for
me I will always cherish our time
together thankfully a condition like
living 80 years in 24 hours doesn't
actually exist but it does make us think
about how important it is to use the
time we have life moves pretty fast you
don't stop and look around once in a
while you could miss it
aging can be a tough ride but what if
you didn't have to worry about getting
old what if we never aged well that's a
story or another what if
[Music]